The Marvel Cinematic Universe has a lot of
extremely powerful characters.
Hey, they're superheroes after all.
Being super powered is just part of the whole
deal.
And fans love to debate just who is the most
powerful of them all.
Is it Thor, the god of thunder and heir to
Odin's legacy?
"Strongest Avenger."
"Access denied."
"STRONGEST AVENGER."
Is it the incredible Hulk, whose strength
scales with his nearly limitless anger?
Is it Hawkeye, who can shoot an arrow real
good?
Actually, it turns out that the correct answer
is none of the above, because there's one
Marvel legend who goes higher, further, and
faster than the rest of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes.
Yes, people, it's official canon: Marvel Studios
president Kevin Feige has confirmed that the
most powerful hero in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is Captain Marvel.
"She's one of the most powerful, and one of
the most popular characters in our comics,
and will be the most powerful character in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe"
Feige explained that it took a while to get
to the point where the time was right to finally
introduce Captain Marvel to movie fans.
"Captain Marvel is a character in our comics,
and in the mythology, who's got one foot on
Earth and one foot in the cosmic arena.
So before she could be introduced the whole
cosmic side of things have to be explored
in movies like Guardians of the Galaxy and
Thor: Ragnarok.
"Now that we've made a number of movies that
take place on Earth, and now a number of cosmic
adventures... we thought it was the right
time to finally introduce Captain Marvel to
the world."
This isn't the first time he's said it, either.
Way back in 2016, not long after star Brie
Larson was cast as Captain Marvel, Feige told
Vulture the same thing.
"It's very important to us that all of our
heroes do not become silhouette-perfect cutout
icons.
All of the Marvel characters have flaws to
them [and] all of them have a deep humanity
to them.
With Captain Marvel, she is as powerful a
character as we've ever put in a movie.
Her powers are off the charts, and when she's
introduced, she will be by far the strongest
character we've ever had.
It's important, then, to counterbalance that
with someone who feels real.
She needs to have a humanity to tap into,
and Brie [Larson] can do that."
Fans saw both sides of Captain Marvel on full
display when the film hit theaters on March
8, leaving no doubt that Larson's hero is
now the strongest one in the MCU.
And that has fans speculating about what that
might mean when she teams with the surviving
members of the Avengers for Avengers: Endgame.
The newest trailer for Avengers: Endgame featured
Captain Marvel, wearing civilian clothes and
looking a bit older than she did in her 1995-set
standalone movie, hanging around at Avengers
HQ.
This sequence seemed to directly follow the
mid-credits scene in Captain Marvel, which
saw her return to Earth and ask the Avengers
where Nick Fury was.
And that, of course, indicated that she had
indeed received the desperate page Fury sent
out in the post-credits scene of Avengers:
Infinity War.
He wanted some help fighting off Thanos.
Well, looks like he got his wish!
Of course, exactly how Captain Marvel's presence
will affect the balance of power in the fight
against Thanos remains to be seen, but considering
the bearer of the Captain Marvel name has
long been Thanos's arch-enemy in the comics
and considering the fact that Feige has confirmed
that Carol Danvers is the strongest one there
is, all we can say is, sorry Thanos!
Time's up.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Avengers
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.